il aura fallu attendre quasiment huit
ans pour que leurs relations
diplomatiques s'améliore la turquie et
l'egypte sont sur le point de rouvrir
une page commune pourtant rien ne
semblait acquis tout part du 3 juillet
en egypte le maréchal à 6,6 renverse le
président mohammed morsi issu des frères
musulmans organisation sunnite islamiste
soutenu par la turquie depuis les
relations diplomatiques se sont gelés et
les deux pays s'opposent régulièrement
c'est le cas notamment dans le cadre du
conflit libyen
la turquie soutient le camp du
gouvernement d'union nationale l'egypte
celui de l'armée nationale libyenne du
maréchal haftar les deux pays s'opposent
également au qatar alors que celui ci
entretient des relations étroites avec
ankara
l'egypte elle a gelé ses relations
diplomatiques avec doit en 2017
mais les conflits géopolitiques du
moyen-orient ont évolué la libye a connu
un nouveau tournant avec un cessez le
feu en octobre dernier et laisse espérer
une possible transition diplomatique le
blocus égyptien au qatar est quant à lui
levé depuis janvier avec la reprise des
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays
les points de friction turcot égyptienne
apesi un rapprochement semble désormais
possible
le 12 mars dernier les deux pays ont
fait savoir qu'ils étaient en voie de
réconciliation
quelques semaines plus tard le groupe
parlementaire du parti de recep tayyip
erdogan a proposé la création d'un
groupe d'amitié turcot égyptien le
ministre turc des affaires étrangères a
indiqué qu'une délégation se rendra sur
le sol égyptien
dans le cadre d'un accord avec le caire
sur leur frontière maritime
si nous parvenons à un accord nous le
signerons cela serait également
profitable pour l'egypte nous ne
considérons pas la libye comme une aire
de compétition avec l'egypte ou avec
tout autre pays reste maintenant à
savoir jusqu'où pourront aller les
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays depuis la prise de pouvoir du
maréchal al sisi de nombreux opposants
politiques et journalistes se sont
exilés en turquie
qualifiés de terroristes par le caire
leur situation reste aujourd'hui
indécise quant à une possible
extradition vers l'egypte ankara a
démenti toute discussion à ce sujet